Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
A Natale dell'anno scorso
mi trovavo in Italia.
Mia madre era in ospedale
con un tumore al polmone
che se la stava portando via.
Io ho iniziato ad avere
dei brutti presentimenti
e ho fissato delle visite di controllo.
Ed è stato durante una
di queste visite di controllo,
una visita senologica,
che ho scoperto di avere
un tumore al seno.
Era gennaio 2019.
Nel giro di due settimane, ho avuto
la diagnosi esatta del mio tumore:
carcinoma duttale infiltrante.
E ho avuto la caratterizzazione
completa del tumore:
che tipo di cellule,
che recettori erano espressi,
la dimensione, la posizione
nella compagine mammaria.
A marzo, due mesi dopo la mia diagnosi,
ho fatto l'operazione chirurgica
per rimuovere il tumore.
A maggio ho cominciato la radioterapia.
E nel frattempo
il mio tumore veniva sottoposto
a ulteriori test ed esami.
Quando sono arrivati
i risultati di questi test
è stato un altro momento difficile:
il mio tumore era piccolo,
i linfonodi erano puliti -
quindi buone notizie -
ma era molto più aggressivo del previsto -
cattiva notizia.
Praticamente un tumore sardo, come me:
piccolo ma agguerrito.
Il fatto è che il rischio era
che il tumore si ripresentasse
e quindi alcuni dottori spingevano
perché cominciasse la chemioterapia.
Ma non tutti erano d'accordo
e quindi, per decidere il da farsi
la squadra di dottori
che seguiva il mio caso
decise di sottoporre il mio tumore
a un ulteriore test, un test genetico.
Qquesto è un test che analizza
l'espressione di 21 geni del tumore
e sulla base dell'espressione
di questi 21 geni
può prevedere il rischio
che il tumore si ripresenti.
Se il rischio è alto,
la chemioterapia è indicata.
Il mio risultato è arrivato a giugno
ed era intermedio.
E quindi non ho fatto chemioterapia.
A giugno ho ripreso una vita normale
e adesso sono qua.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Sono stata fortunata:
fino a 20 anni fa, il trattamento
per il tumore al seno come il mio
era chemioterapia per tutte le pazienti,
era uguale per tutte le pazienti
ed era spesso inefficace.
Ben presto ci si rese conto
che non tutte le donne rispondevano.
Alcune pazienti ricevevano il farmaco,
ne subivano i devastanti
effetti collaterali,
ma non ne traevano
un beneficio terapeutico.
E quindi la comunità scientifica
ha iniziato a domandarsi: perché?
Perché alcune donne
rispondono, e altre no?
Oggi sappiamo perché.
Oggi sappiamo che c'è
un'immensa variabilità nei tumori al seno,
praticamente, non esistono
due tumori uguali.
Ed è per questo che non rispondono tutti
allo stesso modo allo stesso trattamento.
Per esempio, ci sono tumori come il mio
che esprimono alti livelli
del recettore per l'ormone estrogeno.
E questi tumori possono essere trattati
con una terapia ormonale.
Ma ci sono altri tumori al seno
che esprimono un altro recettore
che si chiama HR 2
e questi altri tumori
possono essere trattati
con un farmaco che si chiama Herceptina,
che agisce su questo recettore.
Sulla base dell'espressione di 21 geni,
come abbiamo visto nel mio caso,
si può prevedere se un tumore
risponde o no alla chemioterapia.
Questa si chiama medicina di precisione
e ha rivoluzionato l'oncologia.
"Medicina di precisione"
vuol dire poter offrire a ogni paziente
un trattamento individualizzato,
ottimizzato per il sottotipo di tumore
che quel paziente ha.
Per me, medicina di precisione
ha voluto dire andare nel giro di sei mesi
da una diagnosi esatta
alla cura mirata per il mio tumore.
Sei mesi!
Adesso vi voglio fare una domanda:
sapete quanto ci vuole
per avere una diagnosi
di una malattia neurodegenerativa
come il Parkinson o l'Alzheimer?
Vi do qualche numero:
nel caso della
sclerosi multipla, due anni;
per il Parkinson, un anno;
per la sclerosi amiotrofica
laterale, un anno;
per l'Alzheimer, due anni.
E questo è il tempo
che ci vuole per avere la diagnosi!
Quando, dopo uno o due anni,
la diagnosi arriva,
non c'è cura per queste malattie,
sono incurabili.
E allora la mia domanda è: perché?
Perché non possiamo andare,
nel giro di sei mesi,
dalla diagnosi alla cura
per una malattia come il Parkinson?
Se ci siamo riusciti
per il tumore al seno,
perché non ci riusciamo
per le malattie del cervello?
Ora, una risposta che può venire in mente
è abbastanza semplice,
ed è che il cervello
è un organo molto complicato.
E questo è vero,
io sono una neuroscienziata,
ve lo posso confermare. È così.
Ma non è l'unico elemento.
Secondo me c'è qualcos'altro che manca
ed è di questo che vi vorrei parlare oggi.
Secondo me manca oggi, in neurologia,
una medicina di precisione
come esiste per l'oncologia.
Non abbiamo una medicina di precisione
in neurologia, oggi,
perché fino ad oggi
abbiamo dato per scontato
che non ci servisse.
Abbiamo dato per scontato
che i pazienti che si presentano
con queste malattie
siano fra di loro più o meno tutti uguali.
Ma è così?
Prendiamo l'esempio dell'Alzheimer:
è possibile mostrare come progredisce
la malattia in un paziente
con un grafico come quello
che vedete alle mie spalle.
Qui vedete il tempo, i mesi,
e qui vedete una misura della memoria.
A valori bassi corrisponde
una perdita di memoria.
Quindi prendiamo un paziente,
diciamo che abbiamo il signor Carlo.
Il signor Carlo ha avuto la sua diagnosi,
poi la sua memoria è stata misurata
a intervalli regolari per tre anni.
E, come potete vedere,
ci sono stati degli alti e bassi
ma nel complesso la memoria
del signor Carlo è peggiorata.
Ora, cosa succede se mettiamo insieme
i dati di più di 200 pazienti?
Questo è quello che vediamo.
Questi sono dati pubblicati.
Voi cosa vedete?
A voi sembrano tutti uguali,
questi pazienti?
A me no.
Io vedo pazienti che rimangono stabili,
pazienti che peggiorano,
alcuni precipitosamente,
altri in maniera più graduale,
e ce n'è un paio che persino migliorano.
Ma allora com'è possibile?
Com'è possibile avere
tutta questa variabilità
se tutti questi pazienti
hanno la stessa diagnosi?
Quello che succede è che oggi
la diagnosi che possiamo offrire
a un paziente con l'Alzheimer
è una diagnosi clinica,
che si basa sull'analisi
del sintomo che il paziente presenta.
E il sintomo, in Alzheimer,
è la perdita di memoria.
Quindi tutti questi pazienti
si sono presentati alla visita
con un sintomo simile,
di perdita di memoria.
Ma vi posso dire che questi pazienti
possono avere un sintomo simile,
ma molto probabilmente non hanno
la stessa malattia.
Per esempio, alcuni di questi pazienti
accumulano nel loro cervello
un peptide tossico
che si chiama beta amiloide,
che si accumula sotto forma di placche
che possono essere visualizzate
con diagnostica per immagini -
con Pet, come vedete qui.
La presenza di queste placche
è un'indicazione diagnostica
molto chiara di Alzheimer.
Ma ci sono anche pazienti
che presentano esattamente
gli stessi sintomi
dei pazienti che hanno le placche,
ma nel loro tessuto cerebrale
non troviamo amiloide.
Questi pazienti accumulano
un altro peptide tossico,
che si chiama TDP 43.
Questo tipo di demenza si chiama LATE,
ed è appena stato scoperto.
Con la risonanza magnetica
possiamo analizzare alterazioni
nella massa e nella struttura
del tessuto cerebrale,
e possiamo identificare
la presenza di lesioni vascolari.
Queste, a loro volta, possono essere
una causa di declino cognitivo.
E quindi è qui che entra in gioco
la medicina di precisione,
perché è chiaro che non ha senso
trattare tutti questi pazienti,
che hanno patologie diverse,
allo stesso modo.
Non avrebbe senso, per esempio,
dare a tutti questi pazienti
lo stesso farmaco,
diciamo un farmaco anti amiloide,
perché solo i pazienti
che hanno la amiloide
possono rispondere al farmaco.
Gli altri no.
Eppure vi stupirà,
ma è proprio così che abbiamo fatto
gli studi negli ultimi dieci anni,
perché fino a pochissimo tempo fa
non era possibile
caratterizzare i pazienti.
Ma oggi è diverso.
Oggi, grazie al progresso della tecnica,
abbiamo una serie di biomarcatori
che ci permette di caratterizzare
a livello molecolare
la patologia dei pazienti.
La capacità di caratterizzare
la patologia cerebrale in ogni paziente
è il punto di partenza per lanciare
una medicina di precisione in neurologia,
ma non basta.
È un po' come nel mio caso,
quando ho avuto la diagnosi
di carcinoma duttale infiltrante.
Quello è stato l'inizio.
Ma poi, per identificare
e ottimizzare il trattamento,
è necessario conoscere altri elementi.
È necessario conoscere la genetica,
è necessario conoscere per esempio
l'età del paziente,
lo stato sociale ha un'influenza.
E il sesso?
È importante conoscere il sesso
del paziente, in Alzheimer.
Nel 2016, con due amiche ricercatrici,
per curiosità,
abbiamo iniziato a raccogliere dati
sulle differenze in Alzheimer
fra uomini e donne.
E sapete cosa abbiamo scoperto?
Nella maggioranza degli studi clinici
pubblicati fino a quel momento,
non erano riportate le differenze
fra uomini e donne.
Nella stragrande maggioranza
degli studi preclinici,
quelli fatti in animali da laboratorio,
gli studi erano fatti
in animali di un solo sesso,
o solo maschi o solo femmine.
E quindi non era possibile
studiare le differenze.
Non ci sono dati -
non è stato pubblicato -
per dire se i farmaci che abbiamo testato
negli ultimi dieci anni in Alzheimer
funzionino allo stesso modo
negli uomini e nelle donne.
Abbiamo fatto tantissime domande,
e abbiamo trovato tantissima resistenza.
La gente ci chiedeva: e perché?
E perché dovrebbero esserci differenze
fra uomini e donne?
Abbiamo trovato moltissimi muri,
ma abbiamo anche trovato
moltissimi colleghi entusiasti!
Ed è stato sull'onda di questo entusiasmo
che abbiamo fondato
un'organizzazione non profit
che si chiama Women's Brain Project,
che si pone come obiettivo
quello di stimolare
una discussione scientifica
su questo argomento.
E ad oggi, tre anni dopo,
anche grazie al lavoro
del Women's Brain Project,
sono moltissime le differenze
sostanziali, fra uomini e donne,
che sono state descritte in letteratura,
in Alzheimer così come in altre patologie.
Per esempio oggi sappiamo
che, dal momento
della diagnosi di Alzheimer,
le donne progrediscono
molto più velocemente degli uomini.
E guardate, questa è una cosa fondamentale
da conoscere e da capire,
perché vuol dire che il trattamento
dovrà essere personalizzato
anche in base al sesso.
E quindi, oggi, non ci chiedono più:
"e perché dovrebbero esserci differenze?"
Oggi ci chiedono: "e come
possiamo usare, queste differenze?"
E la nostra risposta è:
medicina di precisione.
Se vogliamo identificare dei nuovi metodi
per la diagnosi, la prevenzione
e la cura dell'Alzheimer,
dobbiamo conoscere e capire
la variabilità fra i pazienti.
E questo vuol dire, anche,
conoscere e capire la variabilità
fra uomini e donne.
La buona notizia è che oggi
abbiamo tutti gli elementi
nelle nostre mani
per lanciare una medicina
di precisione in neurologia.
Abbiamo i biomarcatori
che ci permettono
di caratterizzare il paziente,
abbiamo l'intelligenza artificiale
che ci permette di analizzare
questa mole immensa di dati
e abbiamo la comprensione, abbiamo l'idea
di quello che ha senso
andare a guardare nei dati,
per esempio il sesso del paziente.
Se lanciassimo oggi una medicina
di precisione in neurologia,
potremmo cambiare radicalmente
la medicina di domani.
Sapete come mi immagino io
una visita neurologica nel futuro?
Io mi immagino che il paziente si siederà
e il dottore analizzerà
i suoi sintomi clinici
e poi raccoglierà tutti i suoi dati:
i dati genetici, i biomarcatori,
le co-patologie,
forse anche il microbioma intestinale,
il sesso, chiaramente.
E poi tutti questi dati
verranno inseriti in un algoritmo.
E con un clic, l'algoritmo dirà
qual è il sottotipo di Alzheimer
specifico di quel paziente.
E sulla base di questo sottotipo
il dottore sarà in grado di indicare
il trattamento ottimizzato,
individualizzato per quel sottotipo
specifico di Alzheimer
in quel paziente,
in quell'uomo o in quella donna.
Riusciremo davvero ad andare,
nel giro di sei mesi,
dalla diagnosi alla cura,
per una malattia come l'Alzheimer?
Io credo che, con la medicina
di precisione, anche meno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)